yesterday on the show i told you that
coronavirus vaccine manufacturers
pfizer and moderna rightly turned down
an invitation from donald trump to go to
this propaganda event at the white house
which they call the vaccine summit and
it is
it's a really good thing that pfizer and
moderna did turn that down
because it was completely humiliating
and embarrassing and donald trump simply
could not contain himself once again
blurting out seemingly uncontrollably
that he won when he took
questions having nothing whatever to do
with vaccinations so
let's go through this and you will
quickly notice that donald trump
although he likely realizes that joe
biden
will be president on january 20th he
still can't accept that he simply lost
and this is exactly the behavior we
would predict from
narcissists like donald trump this is
exactly what they would struggle with
so we'll start with the wackiest moment
which is when donald trump was
confronted with the reality that
the next administration joe biden's
administration
they will be overseeing most of the
vaccine distribution
and wouldn't it make sense to involve
them in this discussion
and trump just can't help himself and he
blurts out
he won you know he won check it out
and he sort of tries to stay on track
but he falls apart with lies about
stealing the election
just the humiliating answer the next
administration will be the one
ultimately that implements a lot of the
distribution of this vaccine and will
oversee
much of the future of the way operation
warp speed goes forward why not include
members of the biden transition team
as part of this summit that you're
hosting today well we're gonna have to
see who the next administration is
because
we won in those swing states and uh
there was terrible things that went on
so we're gonna have to see who the next
administration is but
whichever the next administration is
will really benefit by what we've been
able to do with this
incredible science uh the doctors all of
the people that came up the lab
technicians the work
the work that's been done is incredible
and it will be incredible for the next
administration
and hopefully the next administration
will be the trump administration
because you can't steal hundreds of
thousands of votes
you can't have fraud and deception and
all of the things that they did
and then slightly win a swing state and
you just have to look at the numbers
look at what's been on tape
look at all the corruption and we'll see
you can't win an election like that so
hopefully the next administration
will be the trump administration a
continuation which has led us to the
highest stock markets we've ever had the
best employment numbers we've ever had
a rebuilt military if you look at
the tax reductions are the greatest in
history the regulation reduction is the
greatest in history
it leads us to space force which nobody
thought was possible
all of the things we've done and we were
rewarded with a victory now let's see
whether or not somebody has the courage
whether it's a legislator or
legislatures
or whether it's a justice of the supreme
court or a number of justices of the
supreme court
let's see if they have the courage to do
what everybody in this country knows
is right i received almost 75 million
votes the highest number of votes in the
history of our country for a sitting
president
so that's two minutes of cuckoo off the
wall stuff i'm not going to go through
all of it but as you can see donald
trump
cannot accept his loss he still is
telling
lies after lies after lies about the
election
trump then falsely claimed plainly
that it would take five to six years to
make a vaccine normally were it not for
trump
thanks to operation warp speed he did it
in nine months
and then later he says you know without
operation warp speed
it could take infinity to make a vaccine
before operation warp speed the typical
time frame for development
that approval as you know uh could be
infinity
now as i've told you before but it bears
repeating the reason that the pfizer
moderna and astrazeneca oxford vaccines
were developed quickly
both in and out of the us understand
that the timeline was identical in
and out of the us regardless of
operation warp speed
is it's a different type of vaccine this
it's a vaccine that works on an mrna
platform rather than a live or weakened
virus
it has nothing to do with trump it's
science it's a type of vaccine that's
faster to develop
i mentioned yesterday that donald trump
failed to secure
possibly 100 million doses of the
vaccine offered to him by pfizer in late
summer we're going to talk about this
more later
but now donald trump is trying to hide
this by talking about an executive order
listen to this
we're working with the world we have
great companies and we're working with
the world in just a few minutes i'll
sign an executive order to ensure that
the united states government
prioritizes the getting out of the
vaccine to american citizens before
sending it to
other nations now if necessary i told
you we'll
invoke the defense production act so
what trump
is doing here because he failed to
simply say
yes give us the doses he now realizes
there's going to be a supply issue
since pfizer sold the doses trump turned
down
to other countries so trump has come up
with an executive order he's going to
sign
it's not clear at all that the executive
order will do a damn thing
it's not clear how it would be enforced
it's not clear who would enforce it it's
not clear how it gets us a single
additional dose
trump failed again but he has this
executive order idea which we'll talk
about more later
and then trump i guess struggling with
language and physics
saying cases will soon skyrocket
downwards listen to that the numbers
should
skyrocket downward i guess he means
cases will soon burrow down deep into
the ground
very very low strange language to be
using
and then trump actually took some
questions he was asked about
we have holidays upcoming we how do you
want people to be safe
vaccines won't be widely rolled out
until next year
and trump seems to refer to approaching
herd immunity because of what he claims
are 15 percent of people
who got the virus and recovered it's a
very weird moment
i'm wondering what your message is for
the american people
given all the increasing cases right now
about what they should do over christmas
and the the hardship that they're all
facing is that
this fire does get worse yeah well cdc
puts out
their guidelines and the very important
guidelines but uh
i think this i think that the vaccine
was our goal that was
number one because that was the way uh
it was the way it ends plus you do have
an immunity you develop immunity over a
period of time and
i hear we're close to 15 percent i'm
hearing that and that
is terrific that's a very powerful
vaccine in itself so the president
seems to be saying there 15 of the
country already got the virus and
they've recovered so they're immune so
we have 15
immunity right now this is a dangerous
claim for a few reasons number one
officially we've only had 15 and a half
million cases
minus nearly 300 000 that died meaning
we have about 15.2 million people we
know about
who uh either have recovered or have the
virus now
most of whom will survive that's under
five percent of the population
when trump says 15 have had it and
recovered
it's possible that for every case we
know about there's
two point something more that we don't
know about that would mean you know
about 50 million people have had the
virus
it could be a stretch we don't know but
the really dangerous part is we don't
know
whether every recovered patient is
equally immune or how long that natural
immunity lasts
it's possible that most of those light
or asymptomatic cases
may not have the same immunity that
somebody who had symptoms and a more
serious case and recovered does
we just don't know so as usual trump is
clueless
and he's airing rather than on the side
of caution he's airing on the side of
belligerence
later trump was asked why the white
house is holding in-person parties
with hundreds of people violating the
cdc guidelines and trump says
well listen these are christmas parties
officials here in this room have
encouraged americans
not to travel this holiday season not to
go to large gatherings
across the street you've been holding
holiday parties with
hundreds of people many not wearing
masks why are you
modeling a different behavior to the
american people and what you're trying
to tell
well they're christmas parties and uh
frankly we've reduced the number of
earth substantially as you know
and i see a lot of people at the parties
wearing masks i mean i have i would say
that
i look out at the audience at those
parties we have a lot of people wearing
masks
and i think that's a good thing oh right
a christmas party if it's christmas then
i guess you're protected somehow it's
different than
you know hanukkah party or super bowl
party
that's different these are christmas
parties after all there are indoor
events with literally hundreds of people
and then lastly here trump calls
for judges and republican legislators
to have what he calls the courage to
help him
overthrow the election results unable
to accept what has taken place here
i received almost 75 million votes the
highest number of votes in the history
of our country for a sitting president
12 million more than the 63 million we
received
four years ago president obama received
3 million less
in his second term and he won easily i
received 12
million more which by the way is a
record 12 million more
and they say that when the numbers came
out
and the numbers came through machines
and all of those ballots were taken away
and added all you have to do is turn on
your local television set and you'll see
what happened
so another embarrassing shameful
destructive q and a session for donald
trump
and uh as we continue to move towards
the end of the year holiday christmas
hanukkah starting very soon very much
looking forward to it
um we are increasingly hearing rumors
that donald trump is sort of going to
just
go to florida and maybe never come back
to washington dc
he'll just kind of disappear he may
never concede he may not be at the
inauguration he may just kind of be gone
and then maybe start campaigning for
2024 still a question mark
but i don't anticipate too many more of
these q a sessions
let's now focus in on this vaccine
executive order that i mentioned earlier
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable
with the same fda approved ingredient as
in viagra and cialis it can be taken day
or night even on a full stomach since
it's chewable
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet package
they're made in the usa and since
bluechew prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy
and best of all no more awkwardness
we've got a special deal for our viewers
and listeners go to bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our
promo code pacman that's p a p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show